[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRAFULLA RAWAL: Hi, everyone.
I'm Prafulla, and I'm a Product
Manager on Google Play Instant
Team.
It is so good to
see you all here.
And thank you for making it to
the last session of the day.
Last year, here at I/O, we
announced Android Instant Apps,
and we made them available
to all app developers.
Today, I'm very
happy to announce
that we are extending the same
platform to all game developers
as well.
We call it Google Play
Instant, where apps, and now
game developers
as well, can build
Instant native experiences
for their users.
In this session today, we are
going to talk about two things.
One, how app developers
across different app verticals
are finding success with
Google Play Instant.
And two, how easy it is
to get started if you
want to build an Instant App.
Tomorrow, there is
a similar session
focused on game
developers, which I highly
encourage you to attend.
So let's talk about apps.
Our users-- they
love native apps,
be it watching video,
favorite TV shows,
or having a smooth checkout
experience while shopping
or buying flight tickets.
It is not a surprise
then that users
spent 87% of their mobile time
in apps, compared to only 13%
in apps.
One would imagine
then that if users
are spending so
much time in apps,
then they must be
finding and installing
lots of cool new apps.
Well, it's quite the opposite.
The same report shows that
more than half of the users
install no apps in
any given month.
Why?
Well, app discovery is hard.
As app developers, you
all can relate to the fact
that getting users
to find your app
is filled with huge challenge.
And after that, for
users, installation
is another challenge.
To understand these
challenges better,
we ran several user
studies, and we
found that the process
of installation
is filled with friction,
questions, and concerns.
Let me share with you
some of the actual quotes
from our users.
"Apps-- they take up
space on my phone,
and my phone runs slower,"
said one of our users.
"If I'm just ordering
pizza, I don't
want to have to download
an app," said another.
Many of them say
that installation--
it feels like more steps
between me and the information
that I want.
And at Google Play
Instant, we totally
relate to these
concerns and have
been working hard to remove
these steps between users
and apps.
Before we deep dive into
details and look at how,
let's see Instant App in action.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Yes, that's the magic
of Google Play Instant,
and you can experience it from
almost any Android device that
is running Lollipop or above.
In fact, thanks to
our OEM partners,
such as Samsung,
Sony, LG, and others,
we have now enabled more
than one billion devices
to run Instant Apps.
And with all these
devices enabled,
we have expanded the
discovery of your app
to well beyond Play Store.
So let's look at some of
the examples in more detail.
Search-- one of the most
powerful discovery surface.
In this example, our
early partner realtor
has enabled majority
of their URLs
to launch an Instant
App so that when
user taps on any
of the search URL,
they land right into this
fluid, immersive experience.
Ads-- another great
discovery surface.
When user sees an ad of this
interesting game such as Clash
Royale, they don't need
to worry about installing
the game first.
With one tap, they can start
playing this immersive,
feature-rich came right
from wherever they are.
But discovery of
your app does not
need to be limited to
traditional surfaces
like search or web.
In this case, the third example,
one of our media partner,
Vicki, who's in the
crowd today, noticed
that a lot of the users we're
finding the content that they
offer in Play Movies app.
But once users find
the content, they
hit the same install friction.
It was a no-brainer
for them to start
replacing the install
wiki button with watch
on wiki button.
So that in one tap, users can
start watching the content
that they were after.
So we saw how
Instant app improves
the discovery of
your app and make
your native app available
to more and more users.
But sitting in the crowd,
you might be thinking,
all that is fine.
But how is this going to
help me drive installation
that I really want?
Well, that is where
Instant App really shines.
Let me show you how.
Let's say your
friend recommends you
a cool shopping app, Hollar.
You find the app
in the Play Store,
and it does really
look interesting.
But wait a minute--
this is also the moment where
the commitment anxiety kicks
in.
We've all been there.
We ask ourselves questions
like, do I really
need to install this right now?
Is this going to give me all
the stuff that I'm after?
Why can't I do window
shopping, as I do in real life?
Well, and a lot of users try
to do that window shopping
by installing and
then uninstalling.
They don't need to
do that anymore.
Once you publish your
app as an Instant App,
we immediately and automatically
enable the Try Now button
in the Play Store.
For e-commerce apps, this is
indeed like window shopping.
For games app,
this is a great way
to play a game before
you decide to install it.
And our users-- they love
this non-commitment option.
As an outcome, some
of our partners
are seeing instillation
uplift up to 19%.
While exact uplift
depends on many factors,
one thing is very clear--
Try Now removes
commitment anxiety
and engages users, who
were hesitant to install
your app in the first place.
So if you want to start
simple with Instant Apps,
and if instillation uplift is
how you define your success,
then journey is straightforward.
We will show later
in the session
that with few lines of
configuration changes,
you can enable the Try Now
experience for your app
as well.
But once you have
an Instant App,
it does not need to be
limited to the Try Now
button in the Play Store.
The same Instant
App can be launched
from a banner on your website.
And as we talk
about banner, first,
let me ask you a quick question.
A quick show of
hands if you have
come across a banner
that asked you
to install an app on a website.
Well, that's quite a lot
of you, and they are indeed
very common.
But the Install button
on these banners--
it triggers the same
commitment anxiety.
Can our users experience
the app, just like Try Now,
before they decide to install?
No points for guessing that
because, of course, they can.
The Instant App
can change the web
to app banners to web
to Instant App Banners.
The Install button can now
be replaced by open button.
And in one tab, user can land
into this immersive experience,
delivered by the Instant
App that you've built.
And as you see on the
last image on the right,
they still have
option to install.
But there are no added benefits.
One, users have already
experienced your app,
so they are more informed.
And two, you, as a
developer, control
the look, feel, positioning,
timing of this installation.
And you can really
integrate this well
with your user journey.
Some partners have reported
that the installs that they
get from instant App are more
valuable to their business
than the install that
they get organically.
So we saw how
Instant App expands
the discovery of your app to
new services, like Search, ads,
and more.
We also saw that how
Try Now and web banners
can get you started
super quickly
and give you installation
uplift that you want.
But beyond discovery
and installation,
we are always working
with all of you
to unlock critical user
journeys for your app.
One such feature
we are launching
is notifications in beta.
For many user
journeys, notifications
are a key extension of
your app functionality--
when your cab arrives, when
your food gets delivered,
or when your package ships.
I'm very happy to announce that
with this notification beta
and program, we can start
unlocking those core use
journeys.
And you can sign up for this
beta program using the URL
displayed on the screen
g.co/instantapps/notification.
We would love to learn and
implement some good use
cases for notifications.
So in summary, we
strongly believe
that once your Android
app is Instant,
the potential and
possibilities are unlimited.
Let me leave you with a video
of one such possibility, where
one of our partners, Tapcart,
is building an augmented reality
shopping experience right
from the search results.
After the video,
my colleague, Raj,
will come on the stage
and share with you
many success stories that we
are seeing with our Instant App
partners.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAJ AJRAWAT: Awesome.
Thank you, Prafulla.
Thank you, everyone,
for being here today.
My name is Raj Ajrawat, and
I'm a Product Specialist
for the Android platform
here at Google Play.
Today, I'm going to walk you
through a lot of the business
impact that we're seeing with
developers that are launching
Instant Apps, and hopefully,
inspire you guys to also build
an Instant App as well.
It's been incredibly exciting
to see all the different types
of Instant Apps that have been
launching since we announced
Instant Apps last year.
Across all the different
categories in the store,
though, we've actually
seen some really
interesting and
immersive experiences
coming from a few
particular categories,
including travel and local,
e-commerce, games, and media,
including things like
video, audio, and news.
Now, the common
thread amongst a lot
of these different verticals
is that all of these partners
are delivering extremely
rich, immersive, and native
experiences to their users.
For example, if I'm searching
for a weekend getaway,
and I want to be able to
take a look at the house
that I want to book or watch a
video or take a virtual tour,
it's really great to do
that in a native experience
quickly and then
be able to book.
Or perhaps I'm actually
trying to buy something,
and I want to take a look
and see if it actually
fits me as well, like you
saw with that Tapcard video.
Or if a friend shares
with me a link so
that he can play with me and
see which player is actually
the best player for
a particular game,
I don't want to have to wait
to go to the store and install.
I can start playing in
that particular moment.
And of course, if a friend
shares a link to a video,
and we want to be able to
laugh about a particular thing,
I can do that quickly, without
having to wait for a page
to load or an app to install.
Across all these
experiences, we want
to empower users to have
a frictionless checkout,
a frictionless log in, and
a frictionless experience.
Now, I'm really happy to
see the business uplift
that we're starting to see
from all of our partners,
and we can generally
categorize that uplift
across three different areas
including installs, conversion,
and engagement.
Let's dive a little bit more
into the installs number.
So what's been really
striking for us
since we launched
Google Play Instant is
the fact that many
partners are actually
seeing a huge boost to
their organic installs
by launching an Instant App.
One of our partners, NOS.nl,
a Dutch news company,
actually saw a 30%
boost in installs
by launching their Instant App.
Another partner of ours,
realtor.com, a real estate
company based here
in the US, actually
saw a 13% boost in
installs from Instant Apps.
Let that sink in for a second.
Instant Apps is
now a major source
of installs for your business.
Simply put, if you're not
deploying an Instant App
right now, you're actually
losing out on installs,
and it's affecting your overall
user acquisition strategy.
We really can't stress
this point enough,
and we want to make sure
you understand that there's
going to be ways where
you can drive more users
to come to your app as a
result of Google Play Instant.
Now, thinking about
conversions, we actually
saw from one of
our partners, Wego,
that they saw a 27%
increase in conversions
from their Instant App.
Wego is a flight search
engine based out of Asia.
And as you saw from
earlier, Haller,
one of our e-commerce
partners, actually
saw a 20% increase in
conversions overall.
Now that they are
both seeing success,
we're actually
advising both partners
in ways in which they can drive
more traffic to their Instant
App, so they can continue
to capture that increase
in their conversions.
When we spoke to one of
our media partners, Viki,
a popular Asian TV
drama app, they actually
saw monetizable watch
time increase almost 5X
from 9 minutes to
almost 47 minutes.
That's a huge increase
in the amount of time
that they're getting
from users, where they're
able to capture them and make
them extremely loyal users
overall.
And what they're
also reporting to us
is that the users that are
downloading and installing
from their Instant
App are actually
much more impactful and
much more loyal users.
They subscribe more.
They watch more.
And they register more often.
I want to take a moment
here and deep dive
into one of our partner's
success stories.
As you know, Vimeo was one of
our first Instant App partners
to launch.
They're a video platform
for creators to post videos.
When they first
launched, they actually
saw engagement go
through the roof.
They saw over 130%
increase in engagement,
compared to other channels.
That means they were capturing
some serious power users
through their Instant App.
When we also worked with
them to get their Instant
App out the door, they found
that they only had about 50%
of their URLs enabled for
search, which meant that there
was an opportunity
to actually drive
more users from those URLs
that are indexed already
to their Instant App.
And today, they're
actually at about 80%
of their URL coverage in 2018.
What is the result
of all those efforts?
They're now actually seeing
almost 15% of their installs
coming from their Instant App.
And again, our goal
is to try and see
how we can continue to
drive even more traffic
so that they can continue to
capture all of these users.
No matter how you cut the data
across all these verticals
and across all
these experiences,
you're simply just seeing more
installs, more conversions,
and more engagement.
I'd like to now hand over the
stage to my colleague, Ignacio,
who's going to walk you through
all the ways in which you can
actually implement these
features to get your Instant
App launched.
IGNACIO BLANCO: Thank you, Raj.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Ignacio
Blanco, and I'm
an Engineer Lead on the
Google Play Instant Team.
You heard from Raj and Prafulla.
Developers are finding
success with Instant Apps.
What I'm going to
show you now is
how simple it is to implement
some of these features,
as well as how easy it
is to enable this success
for your Instant Apps.
I will cover three
stages of development.
First, how you
reduce your app size
so your app can be Instant.
Second, enable traffic-- how you
can make your app be directly
launched by your users.
And third, measuring success--
how your happy users can drive
up the metrics you care about.
Let's talk about
reducing your app size.
In order for an app to be
Instant, it has to be small.
But we heard from you developers
that reducing app size
is really, really hard.
However, there are today
100-megabyte installable apps
that have an Instant App.
I'm going to walk you
through three techniques you
can use to reduce your app size,
configuration APKs, the Google
Play Core library, and
the 10-Megabyte Program.
With configuration
APKs, you just
need to make a few
config changes on Gradle,
and you can save significant
amounts of size on your APK.
The way configuration
APKs work is
by partitioning your native code
and resources across locales,
ABIs, and densities.
Additionally, we are opening
up today the Google Play Core
Library.
With the Google
Play Core Library,
you can download on-demand
features at runtime.
What this allows you to do is
to build a small entry point
experience and then download
up to 10 extra megabytes
on the background.
Now, these two
techniques should be
sufficient for the
majority of developers.
However, we are also
opening up today
a 10-megabyte program in beta.
What this allows you to do
is to build Instant Apps that
have a 10-megabyte entry point.
So if you're interested, please
go to g.co/instantapps/10MB.
What this will give you is try
now immediately, as well as
deep linking from your website.
Now, if you were following
the keynote yesterday
and the presentations,
you may be
wondering if this is related
to the Android App Bundle.
And you're right--
the Android Bundle
allows you to
build smaller apps,
open similar from
other organization,
and helps you download
features on demand.
So no matter where
you're coming from--
whether it's by adopting
the Android Bundle
or building your first Instant
App, we got you covered.
Tools and documentation
will be available shortly
to guide you through the path.
So I just showed you how you
can reduce your app size.
Notice that talk about
how you can enable traffic
to go directly to
your Instant App.
I'm going to show you
two simple things on how
you can get traffic to be sent
directly to your Instant App.
First is how you can
enable the Try Now.
Second, I'm going
to show you how
you can get these
web to app banners
that Prafulla talked about.
So when we launched
Try Now last October,
developers have
been enabling these
by simply adding to
your Android manifest
a metadata tag with a URL that
points back to the Instant App.
You have your main
launcher and a meta tag.
This provides you Try Now that
you have been seeing so far.
Now, to make it even
simpler and also
to support partners that don't
have web presence like games,
we went one step
forward, and we totally
removed the need
for URLs, as well as
for asset link verification.
So this is your manifest
now without Try Now.
What you have to do is simple--
nothing.
So starting today,
we removed the need
to have your URLs in
your manifest at all.
You can publish an Instant
App without any URLs.
If you do this,
you immediately get
Try Now, as well as
the web to app banners.
So earlier in the talk,
Prafulla showed you these web
to app banners and asked if you
have seen them, and you said,
yes.
What he didn't show you was how
easy it is to implement them.
Get ready-- done.
Just append launch equals true
to the deep link on the Play
Store.
And if you have an
Instant App, those banners
will now take the user
to the new journey,
where from the Open button,
they just launch directly
on the Instant App.
So far, we covered
reducing your app size
and enabling two simple
traffic sources, which
are really powerful.
The next step is
how you can measure
the performance and the
success of your Instant App.
I'm going to walk you through
two tools that we have,
and we have extended to
support Instant Apps--
the Google Play Console and
the Google Search Console.
One of the questions that
developers usually ask us
is how many installs is
my Instant App driving.
Well, we have Build This
on the Google Play Console,
and you can access this today.
Simply go to Statistics,
configure your report,
select the Instant App
metrics you care about,
such as launch and
conversion events.
And finally, if you care
about which referrer
is sending traffic
to your Instant App,
select referral platform.
The results-- really good.
My app on number one is
getting 150,000 sessions just
between April and May.
Or number two, you
see that the ad
campaign that we set up on April
10 is also doing pretty well.
More launches are driving
more installs just
from Instant Apps.
Now, if you want to see which
specific traffic sourced,
from the ones that
Prafulla talked about,
such as Search, Browsers, or
Try Now is helping us here.
What you see is Try
Now is effectively
giving me 80% of my installs
just from my Instant App.
Now, what I just
showed you should help
you understand the performance
of your Instant App
from the Google
Play Consoles side.
If you are integrated
with Google Search,
we have also worked
with the Search Team
to give you these kind of stats.
What you see here is
the overall performance
of your search integration
with your Instant App.
You can see clicks,
impressions, and average CTR.
You may also be wondering,
which specific queries
or which specific URLs
are driving traffic
to you Instant App.
We build that, too.
Down in the bottom,
you can switch
between queries and pages,
and that will give you
the fine detail of
impressions, clicks, and CTR
for both queries and URLs.
This should help you
further understand
your search integration.
So to summarize what
we covered today
is how you can reduce your app
size by using configuration
APKs, how you can download
on-demand features using
the Google Play Code Library.
And finally, we talk about
the 10-Megabyte Program.
We then talked about enabling
traffic for your Instant App
through Try Now, as
well as from deep links.
And finally, I show you
how you can understand
the success of your app from
both the Google Play Console,
as well as the Google
Search Console.
I want to thank you all
of you for being here.
Please visit us at the
Sandbox Tent C tomorrow.
Enjoy the rest of I/O and
have fun at the concert.
[MUSIC PLAYING]